c'est le cauchemar de l'apprenti
conducteur un chaos à peine organiser la
circulation à paris à la réputation
d'une jungle urbaine où chacun lutte
pour les quelques mètres disponible de
bitume ou de pavés une pagaille routière
qui fait de la capitale française
un terrain d'expérimentation redoutable
pour une voiture son conducteur
jusqu'ici personne des cités risque ya
des scooters des motos qui compile des
piétons qui traversent n'importe où de
plus en plus de cyclistes assez agressif
mais donc vous voyez que paris c'est
quand même un challenge pour un véhicule
autonome c'est pas dans une banlieue
avec des rues tout droite
c'est pourtant cette ville qui a choisi
l'équipementier automobile valeo pour
tester sa voiture autonome fruit de 10
ans de recherche
une technologie que le groupe français
considère comme l'une des plus avancées
au monde sain véhicule tout à fait
ordinaire de série vous voyez qu'il n'y
a rien sur le toit il est capable de
rouler en autonome avec des capteurs
déjà de série donc des scanners lidar un
radar derrière le bouclier des capteurs
ultrasons une série de capteurs discret
et un cerveau cacher pour l'instant dans
le coffre arrière dans un simple
ordinateur portable sur l'écran vous
avez exactement ce que voit le véhicule
donc ce que voient les caméras les
différents objets et la reconstitution
en 3d
à partir de maintenant jacques team
system et la voiture seconde tout seul
depuis des mois le véhicule tourne en
continu dans les rues de paris
accumulant les données en conditions
normales de circulation alors la voiture
tient compte de tous les éléments
mobiles et immobile autour d'elle là par
exemple elle détecte le feu vert elle
ralenti pour tourner mais il continue si
le feu était rouge elle s'arrêterait en
plus du code de la route la voiture a
aussi dû apprendre et assimilés le
comportement particulier est souvent
inattendues des parisiens
un camion a paru côté gauche derrière le
volant prête à intervenir en cas
d'urgence
l'ingénieur reste aux aguets ici pas
question de conduite prudente à faible
vitesse le véhicule suit le rythme
normal de la circulation et
l'intelligence artificielle lui commande
de calquer la conduite de conducteurs
humain une technologie encore
expérimental mais que valeo espère bien
pouvoir commercialiser d'ici quelques
années si la voiture est entièrement
autonome elle seconde pour l'instant à
suivre trajet pré établis tels que
définis avec les autorités car les
limitations des voitures autonomes ne
sont pas que technologique
elles sont aussi d'ordre légal ici jean
françois bélanger radio-canada paris